griffin cannon goes to work for the
eighth time this year it's his seventh a
start
his last three have been good at boston
against the dodgers at home
at seattle all of them outstanding
missing a ton of bats this year as
all angels starting pitchers are
donaldson drawing a walk
now counts full to kepler
i think he would get a fastball right
here that stroke to the right field
corner and
fair into the corner donaldson rounding
second on his way to third
and they're gonna hold him up there
with kepler keeping one just fair for a
double and the twins are in business
the twins not only have a great chance
to score they got a chance to
break the game open a little bit here
before the angels even get to the bat
rack so noah double and three at bats
in the first game today mashed
to left crushed to left
a grand slam for miguel cino and the
twins get a big fly and a big
spot the twins jump out in front four to
nothing
chris butera and canning just decided
that they're just going to continue to
challenge him with fastballs
and you know just throwing one too many
fastballs and
you know that that blows my mind that
you have that that good of a change up
that you wouldn't at least show him one
to get him off the fastball into the
angel bullpen and a quick four-nothing
twins lead
jose barrios is tough he goes to work
for the ninth time this time against
that lineup
rios out of the prep world of puerto
rico twins first round pick a couple of
years back he was initially going to
miami-dade these are the numbers they're
very good yeah he's
got plus stuff fastball 93-97 jose rojas
left-handed batting second baseman he
went up and got it
it's a fastball he was ready and it's
gone
that is some super quick hands by jose
rojas his
second career home run to go along with
nine doubles
fifth rbi right away the halos
responding to the grand slam by snow
with a home run by rojas
almost 109 miles per hour exit velocity
running fastball upstairs brings his
hands up and this is out by a lot
good to see his human strikeout of
botany as he
maybe some other angel hitters will get
a steady die to burritos
breaking ball and the 3-2 swag and a
missing doubt he goes burrill strikes
out walsh
on a curveball he strikes out two this
one has
a minnesota slant to it right now
up 4-1 here's the pitch that's hit hard
and that is a fair ball
hit the line it's gonna roll around down
in the left field corner
going into third and being waved home
will be up and here's the throw
it's late he'll score throw up the
second that's
late although that looked pretty close
at second base as
taylor ward after getting that double
was rounding the bag but the angels get
a run on the board and now it's a 4-2
minnesota lead
this is a sinker that just doesn't get
all the way down it stays up in the zone
those are the ones you can hit hard
and ward does hammers it down in that
left field corner
and that left field corner is always a
tricky
deal drew chokes up on the bat two of
20. utera fights it off
into center field down for a base hit a
stop sign was up from butterfield he ran
right through it and he scores
four to three the score taylor ward took
matters into his own hands and butera
with an
butterfield's going rbi give him a
speeding ticket when he gets into the
dugout but he went
right around them and scores on the high
throw
left snyder in center that's a good read
he knew that baseball was down that's
it's a great initial read
most of the production has been coming
from garber's bat
that six home runs 13 driven in swung on
a hit down the left field line and hit
well
stays fair it's gone hits off the post
for a home run
garber stayed at home plate and was
talking to it to stay fair
and hit high on top of the foul pole
and talking about run production garber
just picked up his seventh home run
twins now lead
five to three that'll make your knee
feel good
he threw one too many breaking balls
doing the most damage speaking of damage
into the corner that one goes
well struck against
[Applause]
how often do you see that two baseballs
on the foul pole in the same inning
won by the twins and one by walsh
although they may review that it felt
like it was some kind of deflection
but now they're going to make sure oh
maybe it's the wire past they know
they're going to be able to
what deflected it yeah they're going to
take that away because i saw a
deflection but i didn't know where that
exactly would have hit
but the wire i think that's going to end
up being
not a home run for walsh
foul ball they get the call correct two
and two
mourinho's about to throw his 65th pitch
got him on a breaking ball and a good
start to the fourth inning
by those two swings from upton one
varial says breaking balls
clearly he's not picking that ball up at
all because
he wasn't close to neither neither of
those pitches
refined his arsenal out there on the
mound
and really hit his spots uterus may be
still
feeling that foul tip limps as he
finishes his swing
one down
beautiful pitch and a great spot put him
in a good pitcher's count going to
one two now see if he can spot that
ball got him he hit garber's mitt
perfectly
you can see ohtani i mean on the
fastballs he's right on him
but anything breaking you can see that
front hip goes
and he's all off balance falling towards
the
visuals dug out if you're ohtani and
you've had two pitches out there called
strikes you got to swing at
the point goes lefty's at a high rate
got it perfect spot for another
breaking ball a swing and a miss and the
two lefties go down on strikes
the man on two out and the one-two he
got him strike three swinging at 95
and rogers delivers yet again strikes
out three angels leave one
larning over five with a walk doing one
a high drive to right field going back
is ward and that ball's gone
his first big league home run on his
home turf
and he delivers against the lefty and
produces a huge
insurance run trevor larney
picked a great time for his first first
big league home run
hesitation and a leg kick and then 97
right down the middle and the twins get
their split
in the doubleheader